I remember being seven years old, living in
Iran, and my father would take me to one of
my favorite places.
It was an indoor swimming pool.
Massive indoor swimming pool And they would
make these special drinks that I loved.
And there was a man there who was a good friend
of the family.
They now live in Southern California.
Love their family.
And I remember that every time I would speak
to this man, he would always give me so much
respect.
Always give me so much respect.
And on time he sat me down and he looked me
in the eye and he told me, "Patrick, do you
know why I respect you so much?"
And I said, "No, I really don't know."
He said, "Because one day, you're going to
lead the world.
Because one day, you, as a seven-year-old,
are going to be a 25, 35, 45-year old leading
other people.
I want to give you respect from now."
I get the chills every time I tell this story,
all over my body.
You see, because, any president in the world,
any great CEO in the world, any great entrepreneur
in the world, at one point was a teenager
with a dream and a heartbeat, thinking, I
want to do something big in my life.
I want to make an impact in my life.
How do I do it?
So today's message is directed to teenage
entrepreneurs.
And by the way, if you're watching this and
you're not a teenage entrepreneur, share this
video with teenage entrepreneurs that you
may know, or even teenagers that want to figure
out a way to make more money.
I'm going to share 14 different ideas that
any teenager can put in place, and start making
money today.
Because I'm talking from experience on how
I started making money at ten years old.
Let me start off telling you a couple of ways
that I did it.
I remember being ten years old running a recycling
business at a swimming pool, local in Germany.
I remember being 13 years old, going around
all over the place.
I had a point here, so I want to go with the
first one.
The first point for teen age entrepreneurs
to make money -- it's something I did.
And I'm telling you, I didn't grow up in a
wealthy family.
Some people that are watching this may say,
"I'm from a prestigious family, I would never
bring myself to that level."
That's totally fine.
I'm just telling you how I made my money.
I was 13 years old, living in Glendale, California
and I had a friend of mine named Adrian.
We wanted to buy this card of Sergei Fedorov
and Sergei Fedorov at that time Upper Deck
came out.
Some of you may know Sergei Fedorov, their
rookie card was a fascinating rookie card.
We both wanted it and we wanted to buy a box
of Upper Deck and split the 36 packs, 18 and
18 we'd split it.
And so when our parents would go to sleep
at night at 10, 11 o'clock, we had a shopping
cart.
I'd go grab the shopping cart and we'd go
to all the local -- this is what I did -- you
don't have to do this.
We'd go to the local trashcans and we'd collect
either the cans or two liter bottles.
and we would collect them, we'd go to the
local Albertson's and recycle every single
one of them.
We'd make five bucks, and we'd do that a few
times a week.
Eventually after a month, you have about $100.
And you can buy cards.
Whatever it was, that was mine.
Today, there are many other ways to do this.
If I was 12 years old today, 11 years old
today, 13 years old today, I would go to every
single person in my community that my parents
approved of -- you've got to make sure your
parents can say that you can talk to these
guys, and you've got to make sure you get
the confirmation from your parents.
But I would go and I would ask, hey, do you
mind if I collect all your cans and I would
give them special plastic bags or boxes for
them to put and you'd come and clean it for
them, except you're recycling.
And I would bring that back, and have bags
and ask my mom or my dad to take me to the
recycling place and I would recycle and take
that money, so one, you're being a positive,
great citizen to society because you're cleaning
the place out and number two, you're making
money for doing that.
That's one of the ways that any, any, any
teenage entrepreneur can make money.
You may say, "Pat, I don't like that idea."
Stay with me.
Second idea.
Here's the second idea.
Social media.
Most adults have no clue about social media.
I tell you no clue.
When I say adults, I'm not talking about 22-year-olds,
I'm taking about maybe 35, 45.
It's not that they don't have any clue -- but
most of them don't know a lot about social
media.
And you would be amazed how many of them are
intimidated by it.
For instance, this whole idea came about because
I'm on Snapchat and I'm pretty active now
on Snapchat.
I'm on a 90-day health transformation program.
I'm trying to get to a certain shape that
I've never been before and I want to get to
that.
So every morning I post my pictures on what
I look like, and it's not the most comfortable
thing to do, but I want to get rid of this
gut.
I want to get into very, very good shape,
just like I used to be at 21, 22 years old.
And I'm starting to dialog a lot with people
that use Snapchat.
[Why don't we pull up my Snapchat code so
other people can use it as well.
And follow me on Snapchat.
I'm very active on Snapchat.]
And I'm getting a lot of teenagers that would
message me and say, "Pat, can you do a video
on entrepreneurship for teenagers?
Pat, can you give us some ideas?
I know you talk a lot about business and scaling
and how to do this, how about me?
I'm 14-years old.
I want to find out how to make money.
How can you help me?"
So the idea for this video came from Snapchat
because I got a message and I responded back
to it and said, "Let's make a video for this."
Now, I didn't know how Snapchat worked.
Let me tell you how I learned about how Snapchat
worked.
I'm in Bakersfield once -- Mario, were you
with me in Bakersfield, when Shawan was right
next to me, and I said, Shawna, show me how
to use Snapchat?
And he started giving me ideas about Snapchat.
[Mario: Yes.]
Then I go to Florida and was spending time
with Phoebe, she is now I want to say 16 years
old and for 30 minutes, she showed me Snapchat.
She's 16 years old, I'm 37 years old.
She showed me Snapchat, right?
"Patrick do this, here's how this works, you
need to do this, you need to do that," and
we went through the whole thing together -- you
can do this and you can put your finger and
do this.
All these things she taught me, I know nothing
about it.
And by the way, let me put it to you this
way.
I would have paid $100 for that.
You may be 13 years old and watching this
and say, Pat, c'mon now.
You'd pay $100 for that?
Yes!
Yes.
If you go locally, and you tell your mom and
dad, "Mom, dad, can you start telling friends
and family that I'm going to teach everybody
about social media and how to use Instagram
and who do we have that's business owners.
Can you help me out?"
Parents don't mind helping you make money.
So then you go out there and start talking
about how to use this, how to use that and
next thing you know, you're making $50 here,
$100 here.
There's even a guy, my pastor's son who started
teaching other people -- his name is Dallas
-- who started teaching other people how to
get a following on Twitter.
How to get a following on Instagram.
How to get a following. . . he started really
doing so well that other people started paying
him $300 a month, $200 a month, $400 a month
for doing this, and now he's got a business
for himself.
And every single month he helps increase following
and I know a lot of teenagers know how to
increase following and exposure, that maybe
adults want to know how to do.
I will tell you, if I was 13 years old today,
if I was 12 years old today, if I was 14 years
old today, I would be making at a minimum,
$2000 - $3000 a month just teaching adults
on social media and it would not be a hard
thing to do if I was that today.
Now you may say, "Pat, I don't want to do
social media."
No problem, I've got another one for you.
Fiverr.
Let me tell you about Fiverr.
Can we put a picture of Fiverr up here so
they know what it is?
Fiverr is a website for freelancers.
And you may ask, "Pat, but for Fiverr you
have to be 18 years old."
No you don't.
For Fiverr you have to be 13 years and older
to be on Fiverr.
Now you need parent approval to get paid and
all that other stuff, but you need to be 13
years old or older as a freelancer on Fiverr
to make it work.
So what can you do on Fiverr?
Here's what Fiverr's all about.
You're a good writer?
You say, "I edit blogs" for $20, for $10,
for $5, no problem.
People start sending you postings so you start
with friends and family and if you do a good
job for them, and you ask them to review you,
and your rating goes up, now you're somebody
that other people know, and you start getting
$5, $10, $20 offers from other people.
We do this all the time ourselves at the home
office.
Write, voice, you would be amazed, how many
movies, studios, need a voice for a certain
script and all you do is sit there and record
the same thing seven times and they pay you
$20 for it.
Editing, graphic design, animation, Photoshop,
there's a lot of opportunities on Fiverr for
teenagers to make money on.
#4:Babysitting -- pretty simple, not that
complicated.
Can I help you babysit?
Great, just make sure the parents that you
choose to help babysit, that are ones your
parents approve of.
It's very critical for your parents to approve
of who you're babysitting, while you're doing
that.
#5: Pet sitting.
There's a lot of guys and kids in the community
that will come and say, "Do you want me to
walk the dog?
I'll do it for $10.
I'll do it for $5.
I'll do it for $20.
Great, they go do laps for 20 or 30 minutes,
and I'll give them $10.
I don't have a problem with that.
And depending on the community you live in,
you start watching people that have dogs,
you monitor them when you're outside.
You know, that lady has a dog, this lady has
a dog and you ask them, "hey, would you like
me to walk the dogs for you once a day?
I charge $5 for once a day, $10 for twice
a day," whatever the number may be for you,
and you would be amazed how many people will
say yes.
The next thing you know, if you have 10 clients,
10 dogs, and you're walking them once or twice
or three times a week, you're making $500
a month, $500 per month is a lot of money
for a 13-year-old.
#6- Running Errands.
Running errands.
I have a next-door neighbor, this kid is named
Luke.
I love this kid.
I mean, I love -- I tell this kid every single
time, you're going to do big things in your
life, because he'll come and knock on the
door, and he'll say, "Hi Jennifer.
Hi Patrick.
Is there anything I can help you with?"
Such as what?
Now, family, pure world-class family on who
they are.
"Is there anything I can help you with?"
They'll come and they'll play with my kids
or they'll come and do reading -- so many
different ways.
And you're talking $20 here $20 there, and
we may not think $20 is a lot of money, but
Luke is making $20 here and there and that's
$100 bucks, $80 bucks, and he does that with
five, six different families.
Look at the kind of potential that could be.
#7: Next, landscaping.
Landscaping is pretty obvious.
A lot of kids do it, a lot of teenagers do
it.
Mowing the lawn, shoveling the snow, picking
up leaves, pulling out weeds, cleaning out
the garage, there's a lot of ways you can
do that and get three buddies.
Ask who needs it and they'll pay $30 and you
split it with your three buddies, $10 apiece,
and you can clean it up, or $50.
I wouldn't have a problem doing it myself
and paying for somebody with that.
Next one, #8.
Code Academy is a website strictly created
and currently it's free.
Investors have invested I think a quarter
billion dollars into Code Academy.
It is a website similar to Khan Academy.
They teach you how to code, for free.
You don't pay them anything.
So you're a 12-year-old kid and you know the
world's headed towards technology.
And you want to learn how to code, go on Code
Academy and start learning how to code.
You will learn how to code.
And if you learn how to code, guess what?
I am a person that runs a liquor store.
I want to have a website.
Now you can help me set up a website for $500.
I'm somebody local that your father needs
help with something, I'll help with it.
Your mom, your uncle, your cousin, people
start asking you.
Code Academy taught yo how to build a website,
now you know how to do it.
Now you have a website business.
So CodeAcademy.com.
#9 Sell products and eBay and Amazon.
I did this before.
You can sell baseball cards, you can sell
a lot of different things nowadays.
You can go to a 99 cent store and buy a bunch
of things for 99 cents.
And I'm being dead serious with you.
If you have a 99 cent store near where you
live, and you sell that for $7, you sell that
for $5, and you add $3.99 shipping and handling,
and everything is going from your house, and
you're making money, and you don't even have
to go anywhere.
UPS comes and picks up 20 items you sold,
it goes, you're PayPal account linked, approved
by your parents, you're making money coming
in, so there's a lot of ways you can do that
with Amazon and eBay.
#10: Next, start a blog.
Start writing a blog.
So what do you write about?
You could write about Mickey Mouse.
You can write about Thomas and Friends.
You can write about so many different things.
You can write about movies that come out for
teenagers.
You can write about G-Rated movie, cartoons,
Disney movies.
I met a guy the other day [where were we?]
We were in San Diego, and this gentleman got
up and he was a former attorney, and he makes
$150,000 per year, and all he talks about
is Mickey Mouse, and Disneyland.
That's all he talks about.
All he talks about is Mickey Mouse and Disneyland.
So you could talk about Frozen, you could
talk about anything that you know about Frozen,
anything you know about cartoons, anything
-- it doesn't matter what it is.
Then you create a website and there's a following
and you have your friends and family share
it, and the next thing you know, you have
affiliates on your website, they're buying
things, you have partners, there's advertising,
and many opportunities will come up if you
do that with a blog.
Now do that if you are a good writer and make
sure you get Google AdSense to help you out
with that.
#11: The next one is to start a YouTube channel.
[Mario, what is that YouTube channel you were
talking about, where a kid reviews toys?
Mario:Evan Tube.]
I saw this, I was fascinated by it, young
kid, I want to say eight years old, Evan Tube.
How many subscribers does he have?
[Mario millions.]
I want to say it's 2.9 million type of thing.
Evan Tube has -- let's put a picture so they
can see it as well, let's give Evan Tube some
love -- 3.1 million subscribers.
He monetizes that.
His video right there has three million views.
He monetizes that and YouTube pays him and
he's eight years old, seven years old.
So he reviews toys.
You can review games, new technology.
You can do how to, how to use Snapchat, how
to -- it can be a how-to site.
There's ways, I know if Mario and I were 14
years old right now, we'd be running a prank
YouTube channel and we'd be rocking the house
if we ran a prank YouTube channel.
I would be a rock star.
I would be an online superstar if some of
my friends from the past would know of the
pranks I've pulled, 99% of them we can't even
share with you right now but you can do pranks,
YouTube channel.
You can do online tutoring.
I know a friend of mine, she was always coming
out with, I would mentor her for many years
when I was in California.
What was it called?
[Mario: Tutors 2 You] and she started the
business very small, and she was charging,
you know, 10, 15, 20, 35 bucks and all of
a sudden, next thing you know, other people
are, she can't tutor the families any more,
and other people.
Okay, and she started doing very, very well
for herself with Tutors 2 You, so you can
do that yourself.
You can sing, you can play an instrument.
You can do a cover.
You can do music lessons, you can do so many
different things.
Now obviously, you've got to figure out how
to monetize your channel on YouTube, and you
can click on the link on the bottom, a video
that explains how to get your YouTube channel
to start monetizing, because you need a Google
AdSense account, it's not hard to do.
A lot of kids are doing it now.
And all you need, you can do it with a phone
camera, that's all you need -- a phone camera.
You can use a computer camera.
You can get someone to create an opening for
you, the ending for you.
It's not hard.
You can use someone from Fiverr to help you
make the video cleaner.
There's a lot of ways nowadays to create and
it's free to start a YouTube channel anyway,
so give it a shot and see what happens.
If you're not going to start a YouTube channel,
become a tutor.
So you can tutor online.
So point #12 is tutoring.
You can tutor math, English.
Start local, tell kids, put signs, put flyers
that parents talk about it, and next thing
you know, you have a tutoring business.
#13 is washing cars and detailing cars.
I know a lot of 11, 12-year-olds who work
on cars with their fathers and they are fascinated
by cars and they're just so meticulous on
how they handle cars because they saw it from
their father and what do t
they do it right in front of their house,
tell everybody to come at this time over here,
park the car.
Use your dad's stuff that he has and charge
$10, $15 and wash the cars with a buddy of
yours and split the money.
By the end of the day, let me tell you something,
here's a fascinating thing.
I will not tip a kid or a teenager the same
thing I will tip an adult.
I don't know why that is, but we will tip
teenagers more than we will tip adults.
Let me explain.
It's a psychological thing.
We want to help, right?
So if I go out there and all of a sudden somebody
does a car wash for $25, no problem, here's
another $20.
It's $25.
The other day, we were in Highland Park and
I was looking at some purses for my wife and
my son and I were walking, and these kids
were doing a lemonade stand, which is another
way to make money.
Lemonade stand.
"Oh, it's just a dollar for lemonade.
I said, here's $20.
Why are you doing this?"
We're part of an entrepreneur program.
Remember this for the rest of your life.
I give $20 each and left, and they were so
excited about it on what happened.
And the last point, point #14, here's point
#14.
This is my favorite one.
And let me tell you, teenagers watching this,
we are counting on you to help us out with
this and there is a lot of money if you figure
out how to do this.
Ready?
Grab a pen and paper.
You can do it with your parents.
You can do it with a couple of peers.
You can do it with a sibling and write down
the most common problems that teenagers face
today.
I'll give you a few of them.
Write down the most common problems teenagers
face today and how can you be the solution
to those common problems.
Ready?
Let me help you out.
Bullying.
Cyber-bullying.
How can you help with that?
#2 could be drugs, cigarettes, alcohol, believe
it or not, nowadays it's out there with everybody.
Sex, peer pressure, dating.
I know most parents don't want to talk about
this.
It's out there.
More are talking today than before, but it's
out there.
So how do you fix that?
How do you talk about that?
How do you create a business out of it that
also serves and helps other people?
Peer pressure, comparison, constantly being
compared to other kids, appearance, self-esteem,
career, eating disorder, grades, fitting in,
problems at home, broken homes, financial.
It doesn't matter what it is.
These are the problems, and I want you to
sit because your mind is extremely creative,
and unfortunately, teenagers watching this,
the world is generally going to force you
to no longer be creative.
You keep being creative.
Take your mind and say, "What if we could
do this?
What if we could do that?"
And then all of a sudden, oh my, we can do
this.
And then see if there is a way of turning
it into a business.
Generally, it could cost you $500 to start
a business or $1,000 or $2,000 or $800 and
you can go to uncles, local people helping
you out, and the next thing you know, you're
starting something small that ends up being
something big.
Is it going to work 100% of the time?
Not at all.
but guess what?
Quit Quitting.
Keep going with it.
You keep doing it and all of a sudden, some
idea could end up becoming so revolutionary
where we're reading about you on Forbes Magazine
or Inc. Magazine or Entrepreneur Magazine
or somewhere online that you created something
that is being used around the world.
Because we're counting on you to come up with
new innovation that we can use one day ourselves.
So with that being said, now that we have
that down, we've got 14 different points,
there's a couple of things I want you to do.
Most teenagers that choose to become entrepreneurs
-- you've got to think how entrepreneurs think.
Now this is for young entrepreneurs but teenagers
nowadays are starting to read business books
like never before.
I wrote a book with a very good friend of
mine called Tom Ellsworth.
Tom Ellsworth is famous for being part of
JAMDAT and he was one of the seven partners
when they sold JAMDAT to EA Sports for $680
million.
He's a very good friend of mine.
He's the president of our company now.
He and I wrote a book called The Life of an
Entrepreneur in 90 Pages.
This is because of a video that we produced
-- Mario, when did we launch the video?
October 31, 2015 that got 28 million views
on Facebook.
We decided to write a book called The Life
of an Entrepreneur in 90 Pages.
It's a simple book.
Buy this book.
Read this book.
Any young entrepreneur, anybody watching this
ought to read this because the chapter number
one is probably the most important chapter
and this is one of the reasons why we put
the chapter in there and it's called The Truth:
Accepting Reality.
It's a difficult chapter, but it's a very
important chapter.
I wish I knew about that early one when I
became an entrepreneur.
Buy this book, let's put a link somewhere
on here.
If we don't have it here, we can put a link
on the description and if it's on my website,
it will be on the description as well for
you to do that.
Go, read the book The Life of an Entrepreneur
in 90 Pages.
And if you're watching this and you're not
a teenager, please share this video with other
teenagers that can apply some of these concepts
and start making money.
And if you are a teenager.
There's a couple of things I want you to do.
Follow me on Snapchat -- young entrepreneur
or anybody, and
whatever you implement and start getting results,
I want to hear about it.
Message me and tell me, "Pat, this is what
I did that worked for me.
I made $6000 that last year here, part time.
Hey, Pat, I did this last month and I made
$428."
Great.
I want to hear about it.
I want to hear about your success stories,
because you're going to be a great example
of a lot of other people saying, "Well, you
know, for me to work you need to be 16 years
old and no one's hiring 16 year olds nowadays.
You're taking the excuse away from all your
other peers in high school who don't know
how to make money.
And you're making a grand, two, three, four,
five, maybe even $10,000 a month as a teenage
entrepreneur, helping out your parents to
pay for your college education, a car when
you need it, obviously your parents will have
to approve of it, but you'll have an edge
on life.
You'll have an edge because you've learned
how to work hard, create, make money and bring
value to the world.
So that's the message to everybody here for
teenage entrepreneurs and young entrepreneurs.
And I want to make a request here for you
to subscribe to this channel.
We are growing extremely fast right now with
this YouTube channel and I'm getting more
and more requests.
We can't do more than two videos at this time.
I'm going to have some major projects that
I'll be announcing here soon, so be sure you
click on the bottom below to subscribe to
this channel.
Our goal is to get to 100,000 subs by August
31st and we need your help and everybody's
help to help us get to 100,000 fans.
You know, we get a lot of great commentary
about this being the greatest channel on YouTube
for entrepreneurs and we have so much different
content you can go on.
I know that we can go pound for pound against
anybody else on YouTube for content about
entrepreneurship, so subscribe and watch a
few other videos and share this video with
other teenage and young entrepreneurs.
And if you've got any questions and comments,
comment on the bottom.
And if you watch this video on any other website,
except for YouTube, you can always go back
to PatrickBetDavid.com for more videos.
Take care everybody.
Bye bye.